Hey,
let me tell you this these day traders are out of control.
Okay. Uh, because they keep promising bigger and bigger numbers.
And I wonder,
has common sense checked in with any of these guys. I mean,
it used to be that you would say I made like 600 bucks on a yellow
call. Now we're talking about turning 20 K accounts,
30 K accounts into millions of dollars in some of you guys believe
it. All right, let's check this out. Last week's results.
1.8 million guys, what your do now, currently, as we're doing this interview,
uh, this week I passed 6.7 million in profits from 1500 of your own money.
And so you believe these people when they they're just nobodies and they
claim to have made millions of dollars with the stock market.
And I don't know where the reality checks need to start coming in,
but these advertisements are getting ridiculous and they must be getting
ridiculous. Cause they work on some people, right?
Like people do believe this stuff. And it's unbelievable. Well,
and guess what guys I've officially turned $50,000
into $1 million in just two months.
This is new our trades page. Let's look at this.
We're out of control. This has gone too far.
18 year old turns 20 K into $2 million in six months.
Of course he does. Right? And the tooth fairy helped him.
Are we insane that we lost all common sense, but if you go to his Instagram,
we see who this guy is about. Oh, sorry. That's our next guy.
That's trillionaire club. Um, they, sorry, this is our guy. Here we go.
Ooh. Look at this guy. Look at the jacket that he rented for the photo shoot.
I'm giving away $1,000.
Sorry to stop there, dude.
You're trying to flex on people saying you made $2 million in six months and
your giveaway is $1,000, buddy. You need to,
if you're going to convince us that you're rich,
you're going to have to try a little bit harder than that, dude. I think he,
I think he overspent on the budget. Dude. Look at that necklace.
Look at this car. Look at the jet. He overspent.
He's probably in debt credit card debt from paying for this little mini
commercial on, on his Instagram. He couldn't afford the giveaway. Dude,
ignore trades that I'm known for turning $20,000 into a little over 2 million.
By the way, I love when they do that,
I'm known for insert what they want to be known for. Like, dude,
you're not known for that. Nobody knows you for that.
You're trying to get yourself known for that by saying, you're that? Hey guys,
what's up coffee Zilla here known for my sick car's over here.
I don't even talk about them ever, but I'm just known for my awesome cars.
They just sit there, you know? No big deal, guys.
You also may know me for my gigantic bank account.
That's something I'm known for picking 10 lucky winners.
And I'm giving each one off a hundred dollars just because all the support I've
been receiving, you guys have been helping me out. I'm a millionaire.
So just you guys just cause.
You're supporting.
Me a hundred dollars hundred dollar giveaway.
It's time for me to give back. All you need to do is like this video,
share this on your story. It's like three people in the comments section.
It's a lot, honestly,
for a hundred dollars liking tagging three people and sharing this on your
story. It's a lot,
but none of this is why we're talking about new our trades today because this
guy has a moment on YouTube. It's sort of one of those YouTube history moments,
uh, like the boom goes the dynamite kid.
And boom goes the dynamite.
It's just like this amazing piece of internet that I don't think anyone's caught
onto yet. I don't think anyone's noticed that this has happened except for me.
And now you guys, because this guy ran a little commercial, okay.
He ran a little commercial on lofts, YouTube channel. If you guys know this guy,
he does a bunch of chatting with millionaire pieces. He's pretty,
pretty interesting guy.
But what happened with noir traits is he actually had to,
he doesn't have a big enough following for loft to actually bring them on the
channel just normally. Um,
so the guy has him pay $4,000 to get on his show. He goes,
I'll probably have more trades on again.
I'm all the way you guys think he's a scam, but you might be,
but he's paying me 4k this time. So I can't refuse.
He's out of my once before which he paid three K that time.
So this kid is paying to be on the guy show. Okay?
That's an important part of this to understand how hilarious this moment is
because he comes on the show. So this is a,
basically a commercial and bear in mind,
this kid can barely afford a thousand dollars giveaway. So this is a big buck.
Give away here. He comes in this guy show and rather than getting a commercial,
he gets roasted the entire time.
This guy makes money off people. Not off stocks
Went over that. Well,
I actually just posted. What's your response to that?
I mean people, so look, I mean,
uh, well you see Andrew, uh,
I mean people, so look, it didn't think.
We'd be going over this. I paid you 4k to be on your show.
I thought you'd helped me out. I mean, to be fair under the fold, there is,
he is shouting the guy out. He gives the registration,
he is doing a commercial forum,
but he brings up some hilarious stuff.
And some of it rings really close to home.
But look at how this sociopath answers one of these questions because one of
them is actually about one of his well-known frauds.
This guy is a known fraudster who stole signal information from
another guru. He can't even come up with his own guru crowds.
Ruthless. Um, just so everyone knows this.
Guy's just copying people from other chats. He's not legitimate. Watch out.
Do your research.
Is guys, did you see that? Look at this response, but get this response.
This is something he been caught doing.
He's been caught stealing from other gurus and trying to sell it off as his own.
Now he wasn't even stealing that well, and we'll get into that in a second,
but look at how he reacts to this.
Is that true? Yes. I mean, did you see anything I want to screen here?
Just had my discord open, had my tos. Okay.
Now with that response in mind, look, he goes, he goes, is that true?
You're stealing from people. Uh, well, uh,
did you see me stealing from anybody at this particular second? Hey,
that's not what he asked, but with all this in mind with this,
let's add some context to this because new,
our trades was caught definitively stealing from a,
another YouTuber, uh,
and another guru called stock Hunter trading. Now this guy,
I am not at all, endorsing him.
Literally just take one.
Look at his Twitter page to realize what kind of quality information this guy is
giving out. I'm sorry, stock Hunter. Now, how did he get caught? Well,
new our trades joined this. Guy's a discord chat.
Remember he supposedly his origin story. It's like a superhero.
His origin story was that he made millions of dollars in the stock market when
he was 18 years old. So a year after this,
he's caught in this guy's discord group. Okay. This is his email up here.
I'll blur it out. And he's caught paying for this guy's discord signals group.
And the guy starts noticing that he's on his own discourse signals group.
So this is where you pay for someone's stock tips, idiotic, uh,
this other guy's discord stock group. They were the same.
They're giving out the same advice and war trades is giving it out like five
minutes after. So the guy started realizing, Oh,
he's stealing my stock tips and just giving it to his subscribers as if he
thought of it. So what he did is this. He started uploading to his chat room.
This is his side right here, and this is more trades over on the right.
He started uploading his with a watermark. Okay.
I don't know if you guys can see that down there. There's a little watermark.
He'll zoom in, in a second. And the question is wouldn't wire trades.
Copy it with the watermark image. Check it out.
I started my notes at 6:46 AM,
nor trades came in at 6:52 AM and copied me word for
word. Here is my company logos stock Hunter trading,
LLC. This is a watermark and he is copying it.
You literally can't get more busted than this.
And then imagine the fact that he's,
he doesn't even have the decency to run away and stop being a guru and just
realize, Hey, obviously I was faking it guys. Ha got a few of you. You know,
you guys paid me 200 bucks a month for my discord signals group.
And I got like $200,000 a month. Total. I ripped you guys off, but ha ha.
I was just a prank row. He doesn't even have the decency, the shame to do that.
Instead what he does is he goes on loft. He tries to run a commercial,
thinking that no one's going to catch him. This guy's just copying.
People from other chats. He's not legitimate. Watch out do your research.
Dude.
I will pay for that to forever be enshrined that if I ever create a Twitch
chat or I don't know if I can do this for like YouTube remote.
I want that to be one of them. Dude,
just the realization I paid this guy $4,000 and he's
bringing up my biggest, most embarrassing moment of my entire career.
One that de legitimizes me forever. By the way,
if you ever follow this guy's discord group while knowing this you're an idiot,
because clearly he doesn't know what he's doing, trading stocks,
but not only was he stealing from this guy, he also was asking for help.
So this is,
these are things he posted to the guys discord group while he was still a part
of it. He got kicked out, look at this. Okay? So no swing.
Would you swing anything? He's talking about swing trading,
Shopify two 90 calls for a swing.
He's asking questions because he doesn't know what he's doing.
He doesn't know how to trade.
So he's asking for help from this guy who then he kind of steals his whole
thing. And again, this is not like stealing from Warren buffet here.
Remember who we're dealing with here, guys? This is so embarrassing.
If this happened to me, I would never show my face again on the internet.
But these ti doesn't care. He just keeps going and going and going.
Hat's he's not legitimate. Watch out do your research.
Anyway. I just thought you guys would really enjoy that.
Let me know what you guys think. This is just nonstop.
Where do we draw the line? I think anyone under 30,
we should all not listen to including myself, dude,
if we can all take this advice collectively,
I'm happy for you guys not to listen to my advice. In fact,
I don't really give advice much. I mean really?
I just tell you guys who not to listen to,
which is not hard to do because there's so many idiots out there,
but I'm not trying to tell you how to live your life because frankly,
I don't know. Listen, Jesus waited till he was 30 to start preaching.
If that's good enough for Jesus, it's good enough for me.
I'm going to wait till I'm 30.
Before I start spitting out my guru at times while I'm 31, I'm 30.
I'm just going to create a course.
And I'm going to tell y'all how to live your life.
But until then you shouldn't listen to me and you shouldn't listen to all these
idiots. 18 years old millionaire. No, no dude,
are you kidding? It's got to stop.
At some point you got to have some life experience.
It's the Caleb Maddix thing all over again. Dude,
the kid is 17 trying to coach everybody else. It's like, dude,
you haven't earned that right to be a coach. You haven't done anything.
And so that's what I'm super passionate about.
At some point we got to draw the line.
I know that's going to get a lot of people. They're going to say, Hey, no,
I'm a 20 year old. I'm a coach, but I'm going to say no dude.
And if you doubt me, if you think I'm wrong, come on the show, please.
It's been a while. Since we've done a debate, I'd love to talk about this.
Do you think that 20 year olds should be coaches or math?
They should be running masterminds.
Do you think they should be teaching all the rest of us?
Let me in the comment section below,
I know that's a little sensational and as always.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].